welcome back to the Rich Eisen show not
just to those of you who are watching
and listening but to the man to my right
who plays and is the star and is the
writer and executive producer of Brock
Meyer on IFC good to see you once again
Hank Azaria Thank You Rich Eisen
although i did not write but I sure Joel
Church Cooper with many friends I think
every friend to have except for you I
wrote well but I was in the short you
want issue in which a murder yes the
funnier die short from which Brock Meyer
was born I would I did that and then the
podcast version of this show from which
this show was born you showed up as
Brock Meyer many a time to just swing at
that low-hanging fruit it named Tim
Tebow mostly due to trash Tim Tebow and
then for the media day prior to Seahawks
Broncos yes Unleashed you as Jim Brock
Meyer in the hockey arena there in
Newark where they had the appropriately
which which which player that you
approached as Brock Meyer or any figure
was the most confused by you and your
line of questioning when you were there
that I would give the most confused
award to Peyton Manning he was terrified
I think you I think he actually
recognized I had no idea what was
happening and who could blame him
then why is the Simpsons guy in a plaid
jacket talking like that asking me
impertinent irreverent question Wes
Welker was the funniest okay when I
asked him something about what goes on
at the bottom of the pile right what
goes on to the Bible pile and he's and
he said a guy somebody grunts grabbed
him down there and I said that that
could be the worst thing or the best
thing and he took a beat and said it
depends on who's doing it I'll give him
funny it's nice and golden tate wanted
to kill me why water Golden Tate asked
him if he was aware Rich Eisen that the
golden taint is an award had the adults
at the filming or he did not take care
of that so he he didn't know that that
was happening so he taint he paint
unawares when you're st. ain't he
was he taking cabin uh nobody chris
burrman also now yeah you you you were
there law physically with him producing
right Chris Berman was totally confused
as to what was happening but he was uh
but he was on the floor he just was
interviewed just because he was doing
interviewing and that's the media days
even interplay Ritter given how much we
obviously were annoying him he was
extraordinary gracious in giving us an
interview adventure a glass half full or
heaven depending on how you look at that
Hank Azaria here in the Rich Eisen show
studio congratulations on the first
season of Brock Meyer I mean it was
renewed by IFC day it aired
correct yeah a broadcast for the first
time yes because she snuck you snuck so
not on YouTube and things of that nature
right we got a run up on Funny or Die
had it up for a while right and yeah
they picked us up the day we premiered
officially Congrats on all of that man
and it's funny how sometimes life can
imitate art and it seems like what
happened with your beloved Mets and mr.
met could be ripped straight from a
Brock Meyer episode don't you think
we had a black man like meltdown mister
message if you had a rock Meyer like
meltdown when he flipped the bird with
the middle of his four fingers it was
kind of strange
yeah it's amazing you know I guess the
guys had a lot of practice and he can
make he can make a middle finger out of
four fingers somehow but he did it and
yet got fired I guess that [ __ ] what
you meant was because if we're showing
it on the screen right here he used one
hand - what if he all seems delightedly
thrilled it's like hey fu my friend I
love you
and screw you Oliver but - in order to
put the other three fingers down to
create said middle finger he needed to
kind of do the buffing goal sort of you
know that we did back in in grade school
you know with the hands I'd resume Jim
Brock Meyer interviewing mr. Matt that's
something you've seen I don't believe I
don't believe in that we are we live we
will show that up we could we could we
could pull somewhat of that up but but
well you can actually family-friendly
that this
is that right he black Meyer interviews
mr. med and I think it was that exchange
that might have led mr. med to the
sample do that or lenny dykstra one of
the two of us yeah had a bad influence
okay and so how did that how did that
interview come about how did Brock Meyer
land that exclusive with mr. met Hank
how did that happen about a year ago Jim
Brock mired the Mets asked me to do some
content like what I interview players
and I said well can Jim Brock Meyer do
it and they said all right right and
then it ended up having to be between
Verizon sponsoring it and the Mets
worrying about we kind of learned that
if you pull the reins on Jim Brock Meyer
too hard it's not all that funny but but
it still was kind of fun okay but the
interview with mr. met because it was so
so any are talking Neil Walker and
jeurys Familia and and and Wilmer Flores
and degrom and Steven Matz and that was
all okay but the interview mr. met was
delightfully moronic and was really
funny was a mister met Cathy talk or you
know that's probably what was lovely
about it is I had to interpret what
mister men was doing and how would it
work on the radio right now Hank would
there wouldn't be I wouldn't be get
hated what you described what miss
eating now he's putting his hands on his
head indicating that he has a headache
mr. Mets got a headache that kind of
take you oh my god so Matt Harvey would
not be interviewed by Brock Meyer
because that would I would pay to see
Jim Brock Meyer Internet we got my man
Harvey I think you're after a night
where you know supermodel may not have
continued a relationship with him and
yes pajama is missing a start Batman
Harvey well I don't know if you count
Jim Brackman are doing the ESPN
broadcast but that was just after Matt
Harvey had been suspended is that and I
said so to get this clear Matt Harvey
was suspended for three days for not
showing up to the ballpark which proves
that you literally cannot pay somebody
to watch a Mets game do what are the
will cons think of that sort of joke
what do they I don't know but ESPN has
invited me back okay
support we're still were working now to
do some more innings really in full
Brock Meyer get up like they really
actually
my gym Brock Meyer this my like are you
sure well do you what do you think of
the metal chances do you think this year
of wild card because I don't I think the
NFB NL East is that's the way that
barring some kind of injury meltdown on
the Nats part but I don't know the
Rockies and Dodgers and well and
Diamondbacks although yes they do I
think the met you know they got they
they've had a very good last few days of
pitching now that matt is back and Lou
goes back and gazelle Minh seems to have
found himself again
by the way gesundheit but we thank you
very much yeah
so I I think and their offense has been
good I think the Mets have a chance you
know what I think I think they're I have
a prediction okay I think they're gonna
they're going to get back to 500 fairly
soon I think they're going to make a run
at the wild card but even in the last 20
30 games they dropped four or five but
even within that bad streak they just
shouldn't lived hmm I think those games
going to come back to haunt them it's
going to be a little too much to
overcome up to the prediction the Hank
is their attitude we didn't make a nice
run at it though and how about the Yanks
how about how about I argue or that come
on now come on now you got to give it up
come on in just because the Mets have
had that Renaissance and the Yankees
took that dip now maybe we create a
middle very very good now this was
supposed to be the Mets year and the
Mets are we know in the town and now the
Yankee surprisingly have I find myself
rooting for the Yankees in LA have you
heard any of John Sterling's Aaron judge
home run calls oh no I was a judging
jury oh you got me I'm about to see I'm
inseparable entity it is far I am
horrible is that [ __ ] is no it's a
horrible home run call do we have one
for Hank please can we here we go that
but this is this is a good this is a
good one go for it rolls one on and
drilled a deep right field hit as high
tennis far
he had a bullet line drive over the
auxilary scoreboard in right center he
is putting on the most amazing display I
think I've ever seen here comes the
judge this is judgement day now Brock
Meyer would totally tip his cap to that
don't you think
No Thank You Hank
thank you I don't in fact Jim Brock ma
you know what what is he in season two
or three Jim Brock Maya's gonna have to
come after mr. sterling this year
yeah I'm a wild man whether we already
took down Musburger let's go after John
sterling the best burger now has a
mustache or something well I want to
take a break when we come back at the
end we hear we thought it'd go there
again in 60 seconds I want to talk about
season two a Brock Meyer with you and my
BAE Amanda Peet yeah yeah there is a
tailback in 60 seconds
we heard that yeah I heard that story
that's next year on the Rich Eisen show
okay welcome back to the Rich Eisen show
Hank Azaria here in studio for another
segment of Brock my renewed for a second
season and as you are alluding to in the
previous segment Hank I mean you've been
all over the place you've been you've
been selling the soap and pushing this
up and out there hawking it it's a
passion project and it is paying off for
you and we're thrilled about that and so
I got a text from you and then Dan
Patrick last week woke up one morning
out here on the west coast saying that
there was an event at the 92nd Street Y
correct that Dan moderated right with
you and lovely Amanda P who plays your
love interest can loss yes and BA in in
Brock Marc and I will now leave the
floor to you to tell the rest of the
story Hank because I'm keen to hear the
details I mean it pains me to say this
almost as much to have to almost as much
as having to sit through John sterling
on one car but come on now come on now
what but you know there we are me and
Dan Patrick we're minding our own
business talking about Brock buyer to a
crowd of people and not a secretary why
and somehow your name came up how did my
name come up I think we were talking
about who participated in the short like
Dan didn't and Amanda turned to me as if
and said as Rich Eisen gonna be in
season two and I said I don't know we
try to get him season 1 but the schedule
thing didn't work out she said oh can he
please be in season 2 I've got such a
crush on him that's what Amanda Peet
said and I said I'm sorry at I have to
have my hearing checked ok I can swear
that you just said I have such a crush
on him and but she did that's what she's
got a big ol crush on rich eyes now
what's the problem with that but you say
it's tough for you how are they shocking
like that's like why you like it you
like balding nerded you know maybe she I
guess so maybe she's married to one
maybe she is and she plays she's in love
with one on television literally she's
got the trifecta she
balding their Dajjal was the problem I
had is that dan told the story on his
show and he made the dance guess who it
is and they couldn't guess who it was
and then when it was revealed you know
was that how I shocked and then you use
the word shocked in your text too and
I'm like excuse me I think that's a
little bit stronger word come on yeah
may be strong but accurate so when are
you shooting season two hey uh season
two as just you know you'll be in the
Atlanta area probably in October so you
know hmm I would find out I plan it not
a second answer Thursday Night Football
is coming to Atlanta is that right this
fall in October don't know you will guys
look it up so I don't I don't put Hank
on the pay no mind list and turn to my
computer here to the left you have the
Google actually directly in front of you
yes there is a Thursday Night Football
game Saints at Falcons in their
beautiful new facility down there if
you'd like tickets I can make you sit in
one place and then I'll put a man to
give you and I in a luxury suite number
seven is that oh that's too late does it
really never be there then yeah that's
too late but we also have your pending
battle with mr. freer did you hear that
you hear about that'll be before they
shoot did you see have you seen the new
mascot that the Atlanta Braves have I've
heard about this where were they where
they have fans come out of the stands
and run foul pole to foul pole you know
along the warning track yeah once they
get 200 yards in they release this
character dressed like [ __ ] like true
story it's on your screen right here and
he runs he's a member of the grounds
crew who is a 200-meter world-class
sprinter Wow and he comes and you try
and beat him despite getting a 200-yard
head start and then radio audience were
showing the moment where the fan
realizes he's about to get passed at the
very end by the freeze oh hi boss so
I'll I'm thinking I'm going to do that
you're going to challenge that guy well
I mean for charity well a young kid got
smoked like that what chance do you
possibly know knurl would actually
dangle a picture of a panda peed in
that'll you will on the stick
yeah if one if one will yeah we could
try that yeah I don't know if the
scheduling is going to work here but I'd
love to try season two I mean it'll be
it'll be
who else you have anybody lined up or
any no Joe Buck is going to be back okay
that's odd Costas has become a fan of
the show and Costas is continually
really genuinely lobbies us to be part
of season two so what about my decision
what about Musburger I'm not literally
afraid to approach I don't know that he
did think it was funny what would happen
do you think we should like Musburger
did like because he's do thing is Vegas
gambling yeah that site like prop bets
on Brock Meyer getting back to the big
leagues like well you don't need a
workshop at for him to make it natural
yet I mean we could leave that okay
anybody know Brett do you know whoever
you find that stuff funny I think he's
got to get the humor yeah yeah yeah
all right well good he plays Brent
Mustang burger in cars you mean he must
have some sort of you know this really
does I did not know the Hospice's it
cars three all of them he's always
breasts Brent Mustang bird I missed that
I don't know I know either you got to
come here for your cars news they did
yeah we can work on that for you
alright that I'd love to but I'd love to
I would love to it would be my honor to
present Musburger to make that down area
not only because it would be a perfect a
perfect blend of your show with a bona
fide star
yeah of the profession but he's also no
threat to me with Amanda well you know
are as you know I mean if you like that
you know how far away is it from
Musburger really I think it's a few
Kevin Bacon's now five six degrees I
would think it would be as many quite
frank I know the command center was
wondering if we do get Musburger on
board for this if rich reaches out we go
through and he agrees does the command
center then get a cameo as well in the
same episode along with our steam
Colleen tell to faux on in you know like
you're gonna have that political you're
in yes like you've been harder to get
than that
is he an opposing pliers but you're
gonna need extras for yeah I can I know
well we can talk okay yeah by the way
but being +3 is a major anchor on me
right now yeah it's like it's like a
block of cement tied to my ankle mmm
Bravo my friend in the sea of Brock
Meyer oh I'm just glad you're an asset
in connection with whatever might have
with Amanda Peet because that would be
really awkward before I do let you go be
watching the NBA Finals how far the
mispronounce that what the NBA oh oh
how come on so have you have you have
you I'm sorry is anything me I fell
asleep on sleep takes hey no charge for
that
those were sleep days do you still have
your business cards that say sleep to
Andrew Andrew Newman our friend Andrew
Newman still has many of them Hank would
walk up to people with a business card
that just says sleep take on it thank
you if you would know if you were being
unfunny or you're boring him and your
car does is sleep taken which he just
famously bleep day so if you had the
card you would have handed it to me just
to mention of the NIF I would have
that's pretty good not the Hank Hank
though that yeah next year you given up
on them yes I have given up all because
I'm a sane human being I bet well what
so far whether you're a Knicks fan or a
Celtic fan or a San Antonio fan I ask
you rich eyes dissing what difference
does it make that's true it's all
rearranging deck chairs on the Titanic
all that's going to be cabs warriors
next year's two and the Warriors will
probably win that and flop but the aunt
of the the next part mate I just went
through it that bother that sounds like
my mom going through all the children's
name before she got to mind the Knicks
are so light years away from even being
in the mix of at least you name three
teams that have a shot a prayer of a
shot um they're good teams but they
don't really have a prayer of a shot of
feeding the Warriors now do they now do
that I don't think so right so I think
that's incredibly boring honestly how do
you feel about that you
how do you guys like we I know this
folks in the can't you gotta go no no we
had a major discussion about it on the
campus it's wonderful theater into
dynasty and its history now I'm not into
it
for these boring long term for the NBA
you have 25 fan bases that are alienated
you know they have no shot going in not
even 27 to be honest I think it would
have been more interesting had they had
a little tougher go in the playoffs like
hey Utah won a game or one of these or
San Antonio given them a battle but 15
15 and 1 come on and then you know but
Michael Wilbon was on the show yesterday
and he said that this is great
that the NBA you're used to dynastic
teams you're used to bird versus magic
you're used to Bill Russell winning 11
championships that it is a hallmark of
the NBA to have dynastic teams to bring
fans into the tent um you do not agree
with that I do not I heard I think it's
rod Parkers his name pushing back on
that somewhere okay
those teams were challenged maybe not
know about the Russell Celtics
I wasn't observe all that go down there
were nine teams then right I don't know
seriously literally right and three
teams had a minyan I think to make up
their roster
it wasn't my yeshiva team here playing
but it wasn't that much about right but
I mean what was great about those team
he made the comparison like but like Ali
versus Holmes I mean you think of him as
the greater fighter because he was I
mean those battles he was involved in
where Holmes you know he was undefeated
but nobody challenged him and this is
sort of I just can I mean you know it's
like next year who is like Kevin Durant
and Godzilla and God and a tornado on
the court against everybody else I mean
yeah it sounds like that like sharknado
beats the NBA and then all of a sudden
that's a chance for you to actually win
a champion for exactly so and the TV
ratings are way down I guess the finals
ratings were pretty darn good they were
well because it took as it was the only
thing worth watching all year basketball
well that is true I agree with you and
then there's Brock Meyer on IFC season
finale was back in May you renewed for a
second season
you got any Simpsons news you can drop
here no I do not
it's been a good season we're recording
season 29 that's ridiculous
I know we'll do season there
and then I'm not sure beyond that we'll
probably know that within the year
whether it would go on beyond that and
it's a true harry shearer did some
voiceover work for brock mark he did Vin
Scully in I believe it's episode I don't
remember which one but young Brock Meyer
you flash back to him at the hands of
his abusive alcoholic father and he kind
of retreats into a Vin Scully broadcast
as kind of his happy place and it's
Harry Shearer
it's a mitt you can't tell the
difference between Harry Shearer and Vin
Scully I mean it's so perfect that
impression Roger didn't get sued frankly
12in was a litigious man yes and perhaps
he's not but we would we got him because
it's Harry Shearer well uh let me know
when you're shooting season two okay and
we'll see if we can make it happen I
hope so because you know you got to give
the people what they want any by by the
people you mean Amanda PS correct you
that's right hi Susie Rich's wife if
you're watching I did hey yeah what do
you have a case scenario here for you
rich with the minute I can't know that I
get to hang out on the set of season two
a Brock Meyer oh you guys go in fully
singsong I can't wait to remind us from
Susie get your mind I'm sure this isn't
far but I can work out some deal rich
does the show everything and you guys
you know get to love on Amanda Peet well
sure that I mentioned from what I was
told Amanda mentioned Suzy at the 92nd
Street Y you know correct okay that is
absolutely some harm was on the up and
out huh yeah okay yeah cuz you know
until it's not in the same way that I
love by it in the same way that I love
my wife I know I didn't create Game of
Thrones either you know I understand
what's what when time it is Hank what I
would also add also appreciate my
friends being more appreciative of this
news instead of saying what support is
shocked and less shocked by it yes and
equate it to a John sterling homerun
call yeah
not really she for all the fans in a
game of Thrones I feel yeah the wall is
high and as far as I see there's the
mother of dragons then here comes the
white Walker
Hank Azaria you're you're a gem thank
you for coming on thanks for having me
rich at Hank Azaria on Twitter everybody
followed out of that Twitter handle the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on radio stations across the country and
audience if you like that please
download our app there's lots of fun
things there other than just more of the
videos you just saw you can call us from
the app you can email us from the app
just download it trust me you'll enjoy